ragazzi siamo sul lancio switch siccome
da un po che volevo giocare contro marco
qualcosa ho deciso con switch perché
siamo entrambi esperti o stato questo
gioco e che lentamente da chi sei
può essere esperti è un gioco veramente
schifosi un altro quindi è bello da
giocare insieme
chissà che scusami se il tuo video e che
è partito sotto le cinque cose che lo so
perche non c'era molto da 19 mar la lega
secondo me no mai fatto né livello non
sa di cosa stiamo parlando però
solamente un agitato figlia
bravissimo alla città di namie
cosa vuol dire questa cosa ah che bella
questa bottiglia che sta agitando marco
noti propri esperti sulla faccia tutti i
nipoti figlie cin cin cin cin cin cin
rosa per la programmata senza ridere ma
canino pareggio il gioco è dovevate
agitare tuo punto di dare qui doveva
continuare a citare le tv dico bomba sui
tesori incatenati padrino scatenare il
tesoro si sono lanciato solo con questa
espressione sono balconi dei commenti
fatti
ok governo
e perché no guarda io facciamo
sicuramente indiretto ciao
non bisogna anche nella lettore anche a
fare si consola drizzare dall'arco
schifo è bello questioni l'assenso per
aspetti peggiori prima cosa del cavolo e
che poi anche incatenarmi essere santo e
novanta come fa a essere così avanti 9
delegato del loro bene con una larga
possibile
quando la regola fenomeno si no niente
vabbè la figura del babà sul mio canale
supremazia in questo non so che piace va
bene facciamo un supporto di youtube
ok secondo se devi fare il samurai e per
lo sport ci scambiamo the world's candy
vai via
no ma come hai qualche malato non
rifondatore pochi e madame honda casey
curata da quando vuoi veramente questa è
bianchi ma poi certo bravissimo questo
bellissimo mai più
ah ah ah ah ah ma non è che nosta lenta
e difficile perché ho fatto la si è poi
così via
pensavo queste sì la finta ma quella
maledizione va bella e basta poi mungere
le mucche mangiamo sono lungi tour a
cielo aperto notare che è uguale così da
matri schiacciato insieme
per leggere tiro di mammelle le mammelle
era un vale o che ne so ma mi chiamano
il filetto compilato dovrà svolgere di
più è un ottimo più lentamente lo fai
più lazio alla nostra per sentire se tu
fai gli hanno il contadino
io non sono capace a fare il secondo
tempo il registro civile gli iscritti
non lungo le persone simeri punto da
solo
mamma mia questo gioco veramente e sport
mi piace questa vita da youtube aventi
soddisfatto del percorso di vita con il
fatto è vero se sapessi di più coi
fiocchi cadono non saperlo no è vero non
sapevo che schiaccia dargli un bicchiere
volete nel latte a boogie che ti passa
per in giro nella sa cosa corsa la
voglia di molti no vabbè è partito male
e particolare lo starnuto foto video io
ero ai soggetti sono giganteschi e marco
marco
ma addirittura è perché comunque questo
più veloce tre video come munge nessuno
è ora cambiamo questo prego fai un close
up su marco perché bellissimo così
guarda ammirate l'espressione che schifo
tavolo mosquito mangiatelo se non si di
renderci a giocare a fare nuove
trequarti così per tributari potter ma
non molliamo mai copiato tour di narita
tempo ci somiglia 00 questo fortuna no
ma per come è possibile per un attimo mi
sono sentito un fenomeno cioè sono
andata in un'esperienza mistica 10
riesce a fare quarti quasi avrei voluto
farne uno in meno adesso è partito il
competitor certo da il tocco caudio del
doc driver ricordati di pulire bene i
giochi con nel caso in cui si fosse
bagnato con della stato brutto maiale
allevati a partire dai dai dai che
secondo me non è male o intermezzo
ottenere
mi dispiace proprio dai due pari il nome
di questo gioco preferito su questo
palco per questo faccio cambiare io già
non sapevo che questa con due elle sto
vedendo che padre di capire pari in
questa ma c'erano tre e mi chiamo mai
fatto nulla di male così perché non
spetta certo al momento zero proprio
difficilissima [ __ ] di dollari
jawar kalac
ma queste sono non sono bravissima c'è
veramente bravo in questo caso proprio
così viene nel mio impegno come stessi
scassinano un capo importante risposta è
bravo ma la vera è che facciamo
situazione del tuo errore scassinamento
l'attentissimo dell'utenza si voleva che
se devi tenerlo
no guarda quando gli iscritti e tra
l'altro entrare in sala anche quello del
video è impossibile che si sta così
veloce li facciamo le nex magari molto
pure a dove era maledizione la bella è
bella
eravamo ricchi io non so se non la birra
di andare veloce per capirlo
una banca che culo questa dove urge
cloud share
facciamo l'ultima è però che sia un'area
che non si facciano schifo entrambi ori
il gorilla transennata sia a me si
scimmiotta di pierotti tutto tutto vino
che è difficilissimo questo dove due
volte anch'io e io sto in piedi facciamo
gli store bene è chiaro pari non batte
de villepin
ecco la nuova prova della regione
morilla
l'estensione 42 ma non vale finale non
ero pronto pila di montata e volete
davvero drammatico go release ma ho
preso editrice dall'attrezzo dovevano fa
malissimo il braccio che non fa niente
[Musica]
ciao ciao grado number one di ritmo di
un politico giusto bilanciamento
religioso fra marito e rubiera
l'appello la bella bella e lei ferma di
tantissimo facebook ritmo a turismo b
non è quello di quel punto lato facciata
difficilissimo 2020 aperto come ritmo
[Musica]
torino e vero vincente già adesso no
adesso mi faccio certo ci siano tra
stamattina mi fa malissimo del preside
non c'era lui richiamo nella l'ultima 19
delle cellule di tipo
eccoli i momenti ma perché ho ritmo il
carismatico me pocho assisi tutto e sa
che il gioco appunto provenza vabbè ma
di un niente è tutto così gli impegni
delle gambe comunque attenta ai bisogni
faccio schifo ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto abbiamo fatto un po di
movimento terra e lo fa sempre bene
se è piaciuto passate al carani marco
che fa un sacco di cose del genere ma
anche il bagno
cos'è successo con il come lo volevo
dire l'ha detto lui per niente sono
stata lì si risiede
noi cediamo al massimo video con marco e
jones udivano che ovviamente non può
mancare da ragazzi
[Musica]